HEART.
YOU CARE AND YOU ARE OUT THERE
FOR THE GOOD STUFF.
YET, DONALD TRUMP DOESN'T SEEM
TO SEE YOU IN THE GOOD WAY THAT
YOU DO, AND THE WAY WE DO.
HERE IS WHAT DONALD TRUMP HAD TO
SAY ABOUT YOU.
I WANT TO GET YOUR REACTION.
HE SAID THIS AT THE NATIONAL
PRAYER BREAKFAST.
>> HIRED AND SCHWARZENEGGER TO
TAKE MY PLACE.
WE KNOW HOW THAT TURNED OUT.
THE RATINGS WENT RIGHT DOWN THE
TUBES.
IT'S BEEN A TOTAL DISASTER.
AND MARK WILL NEVER, EVER BET
AGAINST TRUMP AGAIN.
I WANT TO JUST PRAY FOR ARNOLD
IF WE CAN FOR THOSE RATINGS.
>> NOW, THIS IS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
YOU ARE LAUGHING.
HE IS LAUGHING.
>> I THINK IT'S FUNNY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES IN A PRAYER BREAKFAST
SAYS THIS.
WHY DO YOU THINK IT'S FUNNY?
>> I THINK IT'S FUNNY HE USES A
PRAYER BREAKFAST.
PLUS, YOU KNOW, I HAVE THICK
SKIN.
THIS DOESN'T BOTHER ME AT ALL.
IT'S VERY FUNNY.
IT GAVE ME AN OPPORTUNITY TO GO
AND SHOUT BACK AND SAY, YOU
KNOW, THE SHOW DIDN'T DO WELL
BECAUSE ONE-THIRD OF THE
AUDIENCE LEFT BECAUSE THEY
BOYCOTT BECAUSE YOU ARE THE
EXECUTIVE PRODUCER, DONALD
TRUMP.
IF YOU NOT OPEN UP YOUR MOUTH
AND TELL EVERYBODY THAT YOU
EXECUTIVE PRODUCER, WE WOULD
HAVE HAD GREAT RATINGS ON THE
SHOW.
BUT THEY ADVERTISERS LEFT.
THE AUDIENCE LEFT.
THEY HATE THE GUY.
THEY LEFT.
SO I WAS CAUGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF
THIS
THEM, 17 OF THEM ON THEMOWED TH
DOWN.
HOW DOES IT MAKE YOU FEEL WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THE PARTY -- THOSE REPUBLICAN
VOTERS, THEY MAY NOT LIKE YOUR
SHOW.
THEY SURE LIKE DONALD TRUMP.
>> THAT'S PERFECTLY FINE.
I THINK THAT DONALD TRUMP WON
THE PRESIDENCY.
I CALLED HIM RIGHT AFTER HE WON.
I SAID CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU ARE NOW OUR PRESIDENT.
ANYTHING I CAN DO, I WILL